one of my close advisors told me if i
didn't agree to sell the company right
now
i would regret that decision for the
rest of my life
relationships were so afraid
that within a year or so every single
person on our management team was gone
that was my hardest time leading
facebook in the 21st century we can say
that we've been privileged to see some
of the greatest next steps of mankind
led by her most brilliant minds like
bill gates larry ellison larry page and
sergey brin jeff bezos steve jobs and of
course elon musk the wealthiest person
in the world the king of social media
however remains mark elliott zuckerberg
and in this video we'll take a look at a
day in the life of facebook ceo oops my
bad mettas ceo we're taking a day in the
life of meta's ceo to discover if he's a
robot alien or lizard person as all the
rumors say i am not a lizard and you
know in defensive mark lizards start out
their day laying on a hot rock under the
morning sun to jumpstart their
metabolism mark on the other hand starts
his day on a bed and instead of
metabolizing vitamin d and regulating
body temperature the first thing he does
is pick up his phone and go through
facebook facebook messenger and whatsapp
he wakes up by 8am and before even
putting on his contacts he takes his
time on these apps something he has
admitted to being bad for his eyes
however waking up by 8 am may not have
always been the norm from mark seeing as
in the early days of the company the
workplace was like a frat house where
everyone came late to work worked late
and partied even more late into the
night at work but after having a family
a lot of that had to change exercise is
very important to mark and he has a
session three times a week sometimes
it's in the gym but he has said that
running is one of his favorite ways to
exercise and he brings his mop sorry his
dog on some of these runs beast as it is
called is a hungarian sheepdog that adds
some color and humor to the activity
your toast is ready
all right
it's time for my call with shrek can you
get him on the video conference line
setting up the bc room now next it's
time for breakfast and mark isn't picky
about what he eats he has so much on his
plate that he sometimes barely lets his
food touch the plate before he eats it i
guess that's just his programming and
his choice of clothing is just as simple
in fact mark zuckerberg the ceo of one
of the biggest companies on earth is
just a pair of timberlands away from
looking like a construction worker
you'll always find him in his gray
t-shirt and a pair of jeans even cartoon
characters don't have this abundance of
the same attire all the time however
these t-shirts are not cheap they are
custom made for comfort by italian
designer brunello cuccinelli also known
as the king of cashmere they cost 400 a
piece and mark's smart home eats one to
him every morning when he's ready to go
to work his choice of simple foods and
clothes is based on his principle of
making the simplest choices possible so
that he doesn't have to spend too much
time making a decision on less important
things when he could be making decisions
to turn real experiences into virtual
ones that's right we all know about meta
by now like i said earlier we're living
in one of the most exciting times in
history where we have this guy an
alleged human trying to colonize mars
and this guy an alleged alien trying to
take over the earth and metta is a big
part of zuck's day when he gets to work
during the day however unbeknownst to
many it has been on his mind for a long
time way back in 2014 during a q a
session at singhua university in china
mark was asked by a student what he
thought would be the future of tech he
said that there were three things he saw
as being important number one connect
the entire world number two artificial
intelligence and number three virtual
reality
these three things take up mark's time
at work facebook sorry meta has already
started plans to connect the world one
of their biggest projects is their
billion dollar 37 000 undersea cable
moving around the continent to provide
fast and reliable internet to 23
countries on the continent in terms of
artificial intelligence meta-ai has also
begun developing projects like deep fake
detection dense pose and ai for commerce
which will make online shopping easy for
both buyers and sellers and in terms of
virtual reality well it's been on
everyone's mouth the tech that everyone
has been scared of for its potential to
turn us into wally people with screens
attached to our faces but it remains to
be seen if the metaverse makes humanity
go full ready player one zuck spends 50
to 60 hours a week working on facebook
but another thing that occupies mark's
time is the amount of traveling he has
to do and when he travels his schedule
is a bit different he spends a lot on
security and private jet charter when he
meets up with people like donald trump
pope francis president emmanuel macron
and even then diesel he also spends time
on some guilty pleasures of his like
reading or learning a language in 2015
he made a resolution to read a new book
every two weeks and this timetable is
peculiar since it gives him flexibility
in terms of learning new languages mark
is very impressive
[Laughter]
imagine my surprise seeing mark
zuckerberg not only speaking mandarin
chinese one of the hardest languages to
learn but also telling a genuinely funny
joke in fact his wife priscilla chan
even said that he used to be better at
the language than her now i know there
are probably memes in your head about
him successfully installing the mandarin
language package into his software but
no mark did actually take a whole year
to learn the language and he does so for
other languages too during the pandemic
his daily activities were a bit
different turns out staying at home will
do that to you mark and priscilla say
that they don't keep work away from home
so we can be sure that mark still worked
on facebook while he and his wife worked
together on their joint company the chan
zuckerberg initiative and now
four-year-old company funding
achievements in medical science and
other fields one other activity that the
couple shared especially during
lockdowns was mark's haircuts priscilla
helped him with the trim which has
caused a lot of discussion on social
media with one user saying that it might
have something to do with mark's love
for augustus caesar the first emperor of
ancient rome this love has been
confirmed by priscilla herself as she
once said he couldn't stop talking about
augustus caesar when they went on their
honeymoon in rome and wouldn't you know
it one of their beautiful daughters is
even named august the caesar cut as it
had been dubbed is named after julius
caesar himself the great uncle of
augustus caesar and sure priscilla can
complain about how much zuck loves to
talk about his passions but what is also
undeniable is that he loves his family
deeply deep enough to make even this guy
jealous at night time every week mark
and priscilla have what is called date
night how often is date night and what
is date we're pretty good about that we
do it every week yeah and no work talk
on date night no work talk who started
date night whose idea was that it's
mark's idea really yes
mark are you the sentimental one in this
relationship mark even said that
facemash and not facebook was the most
important product he built at harvard
because it led him to priscilla today in
their marriage priscilla confirms that
he comes back late sometimes due to work
but he makes up for it all by spending
quality time with her and the kids like
fridays where the entire family gets
together to make use of their worn out
recipe book to make hollow bread for
shabbat when mark comes home to tuck in
his two daughters at night he says a
traditional jewish prayer meesha barach
that goes like this may the source of
strength who's blessed the ones before
us help us find the courage to make our
lives a blessing the robot jokes might
be on us at the end of the day because
while we prove that we're humans by
identifying a truck or a traffic light
mark zuckerberg proves he's human by
showing a lot of love to his family at
the end of the day mark has taken care
of the biggest social media companies in
the world managed several companies to
connect the world and take us to the
future and still made time for his
family that's how you live each day if
you're a mark zuckerberg you can check
out this video while you're still here
and as for mark's legacy well why don't
you ask him yourself you seem to be
replacing larry and sergey
as the people out here who everyone's
talking about you're just staring at is
that a question